Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday. Sorry for Thursday.
No, it isn't. It's not the money. My, it's
a Thursday afternoon, just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast at [inaudible].
Just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
How you doing? What are you,
what are you done today?
How did you watch the news?
Did you fill your head up with all
the fucking craziness on the news?
Isn't it great watching the news? Oh yeah.
Hey, I'm waking up. I'm feeling good.
You know what?
Let's turn on the news.
Why would you put on the fucking news?
What are you going to see?
Are you going to see an accurate
portrayal of what's going on?
Sticking out the fucking window? I
look at your neighbor. Hey Buddy.
I look at him walking out to his car
with his little brown sack with this
fucking lunch in it. Oh,
is he saluting Hitler?
You know, it's just, ah,
is he got a bomb strapped around his
waist as he got a mosquito on his head
that's biting him and Zoe
has babies with little heads.
Yeah.
Jesus fucking
Christ the Goddamn the hysteria,
the hysteria that these
news organizations,
social media in all of this shit has
created. Yeah. Can you just need,
I'm just, I'm fucking one block in a
way, man. I'm walking away. I'm done.
I don't need to know what's going on.
I don't need to be informed. Okay.
Because walking around in a constant
state of fucking hysteria is,
I don't think that that
is being informed when,
yeah,
my real, my reality, my day
to day is I get in a car,
I drive to a building and I write
dialog for cartoon characters.
Occasionally I get to play drums.
I do stand up,
I hang out with my wife in his,
that by right.
I hang out with my daughter and that's it.
But I put on the news and I will literally
think that there's a glacier melting
right above me that's going to drown me.
Polar bears are going to swim in and eat
me with fucking a bomb strapped around
their fucking waste.
That'd be body fucking relax,
fucking relax and all these people fucking
going on there and they just show and
show. Got On TV and told Trump
supporters. I love these people that like,
you know, on these fucking news channels,
they go on and they fucking, you know,
give the other side a piece of their
mind is if the other side even sees it,
they're too busy, like watching their
own shit. And even if they see your shit,
you're not going to sway them.
Equate it to the,
all those years I lived in New
York City as a Boston red sox fan.
During that time I didn't have
money for the baseball package,
so I used to watch the yes network.
I always watched Janky home games,
always home and away,
whatever.
I rooted against them the
entire time I watched them.
I watched more Yankee Games from 1999
to 2007 then I watched red sox games.
So in theory I should have become
a Yankee fan, but I, I did not.
Yeah.
Because I was a staunch,
uh,
red freckled faced red
sox fan and that's it.
So all these people going on TV
talking about these fucking people.
Now these fucking jerk offs are
going to go up to Boston, right?
You know, 18 fucking jerk offs, you know,
I know it's more than that, but everybody,
oh my God,
or the nats,
he's taken over and then they're going
to take it to show the fucking footage of
Boston and busing and all of that
shit from way back in the fucking day.
Is this a perfect storm or racism?
Is Hitler really dead when we return?
His body was never found.
Okay.
According to reports,
there was an angry looking jerk off
riding around in a Mercedes Benz spotted
just last year
down in South America.
Um,
I'm done with all of them.
Absolute fucking hysteria out there.
These people are losing
their fucking minds,
losing their minds,
screaming and yelling at each other.
Nobody's listening to anybody.
Everybody's acting like
the fucking sky is falling.
One fat fuck shoots off a fucking
missile and everybody loses their shit.
One missile, we do that every
fucking day, but worry about this guy
when fucking fat guy with,
I just don't understand the level of
fucking freak out that's going on.
You know,
it's fine.
Yankees of playing the red
sox this weekend. All right.
College football's coming up.
Nfl Football,
baseball playoffs are coming.
It's all going to be fine.
All right.
I gotta tell you,
there's always been Nazi supporters
and they've kind of always had rallies,
but at, it's not like they're
growing, you know what I mean?
Are they, I mean, I just, I
gotta be honest with you. You,
you don't get any whiter than me
and I've never gotten a flyer.
No one's ever asked me to join. I
don't walk down the street. Hey, hey,
okay.
Guten tag.
Look, I'm not saying these
aren't important issues,
but I'm just saying that the level
that people are fucking freaking out.
All right? Just need to fucking
relax. Just fuck of a Laxman.
Okay.
You can vote against whoever you
want to vote against very soon,
right? Isn't it like midterm elections
and then there's this other shit.
You know it's going to happen. You
know what's going to happen. Okay?
There's this fucking country
goes, wait, gone way over here.
We're going to go back and back over here.
So anyways,
whatever. How are you doing? How
was your Thursday afternoon? Huh?
Got Good people in your life. Do
you have a sandwich today? Ah,
I wasn't that delicious.
Was there a terrorist in your sandwich?
Was there a little Nazi flag on the
fucking toothpick that they stuck in your
fucking club sandwich there?
Pr.
I'm going to say there wasn't,
I'm going to go out on a limb and
I'm actually doing the Trump hand thing
right now where you put your index
finger and you're on your thumb.
I like it.
The other three fingers stickup
you know what's great about it?
You really feel like you fucking
drive and your point home.
I'm going to start doing
that with my wife. Okay.
I'll tell you right now there's going
to be cold, cold beer in the fridge.
Um,
you know at the biggest crisis in my
life is right now is I cannot fucking,
I cannot sustain
a work out or eating well
for any significant amount
of times to prevent me from
staying at the fucking weight or
gaining weight. I just can't do it.
This fucking writer's room.
You're just sitting in there with all
these people you love watching them slowly
die. That's what it is. Because no
matter how few calories you eat,
you're sitting on your fucking ass for
eight to 10 hours a day and you just
can't.
You can't fucking do it.
I'm so fucking pissed at myself right now.
I'm going to have to
start doing two a days.
I'm going to workout in the morning
and I'm just going to have to like,
I don't know what to do. Went
out last night and I did, uh,
I did a show down at Largo and I
stopped eating it. Like, you know,
I don't know when the fuck I didn't
want to have like five o'clock.
I don't even remember what I had for
dinner. Five 30 or something like that.
Oh. Then I got down to the club and I
was hungry and I went to this vegetarian
restaurant, those fucking
things. Oh, I didn't eat meat.
Yeah, but what did you eat?
What was in that fucking sauce? You know,
it's gone right to your fucking ass,
right. Your stomach. And then, um,
you know, I have one,
one whiskey. That was it.
And then I came home and
I'm fucking starving.
My wife had a little bit of Thai food
and I had that and I'm just, I'm fucked.
I'm killing my side. I
don't know. I, I gotta,
I gotta I don't know what
happened to by discipline. Um,
I dunno. I'm just under a lot
of fucking stress right now.
I guess that's why I'm having
this reaction to the fucking news.
And everybody's watching it and then
they are coming in and they're like,
can you fucking believe this? Can you
fucking believe this? It's just like,
all right, Kay. You know, it'd
be great in the news that they,
if they showed the amount of fucking
people last week who didn't get in a car
and plow down a bunch of fucking people,
like a complete piece of shit,
that would be the rest of us.
Then this one fucking asshole does it.
And then everybody starts thinking,
is this what the world's going to be
like now? Is this going to happen?
It's just how fucking,
I don't know how awful a fucking parents
did that person have Jesus Christ.
You know?
I think when your kid starts putting
like the Hitler poster on the wall,
it's time to be a little more involved.
Maybe sign them up for volleyball or
something. Try to get them out there,
you know?
All right.
I Dunno what you do with that.
Is there a hotline for that?
A one 800.
My son's into Hitler.
A one 800. I keep finding two
holes poked in the pillow cases.
Um, you know what I mean?
There's unconditional love
and then there's Hitler.
Right? Who's kidding who, and then it's
Kinda like, all right. You know what? Uh,
I think it's a time to ship you off to
the loony Bin and let's make a new kid.
It's time to make a new kid shot.
You know what?
You're like an old star
Steinburg Gulf,
which you like Brett Farve when he
got shipped to the fucking jets.
It's all there for you. It's over. Okay.
You can't make the pass across the
field anymore. You know what I mean?
You've lost your vision, ed.
You got posters, a Hitler,
it's over with Trey to you,
to the New York jets and what bringing in
the nose. That baby, she had a baby man.
We're having a fucking,
that's what I would do.
Yeah.
By kid became a racist.
I would fucking turn my kid in and then I
would just make a new kid. That's it. I,
you know, go back to the
draft. You know what I mean?
I maybe adopt basically
signed a free agent.
Yeah.
You really have to have a strict no
Hitler fucking policy and your house.
You just have to have it.
Um, anyways, I saw this thing where, uh,
people were going on to an white people
go into an and ancestry.com and we're
not pleased with some of
the results. Yeah. I mean,
that's going to happen,
right? It's going to happen.
You're going to find a couple of surprises
in there that's going to fuck up.
Fuck with your manifesto. You know,
I would love if he could fucking,
what the fuck did they
do with Hitler anyways? What
do you mean? Even if he lived,
he's gotta be dead by now. Right. And
what was that guy born 1890 something.
He's so evil. Like maybe he's still
alive. Just the hate is keeping him going.
Yeah.
You know,
just picture them with like a fucking
s s walker screaming with every step
trying to get to the fucking toilet,
you know,
to take a master race shit.
Ah,
if
they only just encouraged
his painting at that,
it only happened that you wouldn't have
all this craziness. Why you still want,
they'd find something else anyways,
socks up, down, up, down, up,
down against this week it a Yankees,
I think they won last
night against the mets.
So the red sox Yankees
played this weekend. Right.
Everybody's going to have a
good time and enjoy the game.
I take way out to the ball game,
take me out to the crowd,
buy me some peanuts and cracker jacks,
you know,
scan your fingerprints at fucking tiger
stadium because you are a fucking dope
opal. So anyways, I'm going to
start doing two a day workouts.
That's when I got to do it. And I just
have to, I have to fucking commit.
MMM.
I'm trying to figure out this new life
that I have with this fucking writer's
room because it takes up so much,
so much of my head
time that um,
you know, I have a very finite
amount of time to fucking work out.
It's still actually keep my standup back
going and all of this shit and I think
it's causing me stress.
And uh, maybe that's the fucking
problem. Maybe I'm just old.
I Dunno. I got a fight. A dude,
I can't have the fucking dead,
but you know,
we just like just thick it big fucking
you stupid skinny arms coming out the
side that Mr. Potato Head,
fucking body, you know,
I can't fucking do it.
I guess also because I blew out my
shoulder, which is finally the thing is,
is better now I'm going really slow.
Add the a the rotator cuff shit going on.
Right. So I'm now, this morning I actually
for the first time in like a year,
I had the fucking Bob Bell and I was
benching and I had five pounds on each
side.
That's how long and slow this processes.
And I felt like the,
just a little something and I was
going to do three sets and I said I
immediately stopped, which is what
you have to do with an injury.
So you'd have to immediately
go, you know what? Fuck this.
I'm not doing this anymore. So
anyways, let's, let's, you know, let's,
let's Google some news.
Yeah.
Google cans cancels domain
registration for daily stormer.
All right,
let's see what we got here.
Google has canceled all this is
going to be more hate groups. Shit.
Justin Bieber may been unknown. 17
year old, famous with a single picture.
Uh,
really a reporter calls out Huckabee's
claim that countless FBI employees were.
That's like reporting.
Now you just put,
your headline is really three death foods.
You should avoid
death foods.
Okay.
All right, let's just
read this one. Let's see,
we see we are canceling daily stormers
registration with Google domains for
violating our terms of
service. This supposed person
told business insider, well,
where the fuck was this a while ago?
Uh,
you read Google's registration agreement,
you can read it here. Okay, go, go.
Didn't want it.
Service used to incite violence.
A source close to Google
told business insider. Um,
I dunno, I hate to do
the Cliche, but when you,
those fucking white supremacist groups,
they just, the dumbest fucking people
look at this fucking guy.
Okay?
It's like if they went there, they
made a movie about white supremacists.
Guy went to the casting.
I Dunno,
I don't get people who go down and protest
the fucking these hate groups just to
let him go down there and screaming,
yell to nobody.
You know what I mean? Why do you go
down there and then what do you do?
You start tearing their signs down
as if they're going to be like, oh,
they tore our side down.
Now I see their fucking,
now I see this side of it.
All you're doing is reinforcing it in
their head that you guys are fucking
assholes.
You should go down there.
You should make them a little pumpkin pie,
little apple pie and just give him
some food and just be nice to them.
That's what we should do with that
fucking guy that fatty over there in North
Korea.
You know,
Bob's trumpet go over there and smoke
a cigar with the talk about grabbing
pussies. Whatever the fuck
you wanted to do, you know?
Yeah.
Instead of using the old book, we do that.
We're going to do this. All right. Um,
oh God.
I have to get out of this vortex here.
I just fucking Google News Boston to
hate groups. You're not welcome here.
Ah, you're not welcome
here. We got plenty of VI.
Hate is already here in Boston
that,
that
it'll be funny if other racists in
Boston were upset about the racist coming
here. They're going to take our,
Hey, I think I'd take her jobs, man.
Okay.
Doh.
We can't have a bunch of other people
coming up here dropping the fucking Edward
or what are we going to dote in?
You're not wanted here. Dope. We're not
hiring. We got fucking plenty of them.
Um, anyways. Uh, what else? What
else? I got nothing going on,
dude.
I'm just sitting in a fucking writer's
room eating salads and somehow putting on
weight because at the end of the day, I
fuck it up. But last night I was at Largo.
I've got one more show down there
tonight. Um, I worked with Joe Barton,
nick and Todd rex to
absolute fucking bese and um,
they killed it last night. We're going
to be down there again tonight for a,
a a great cause. A friend of mine, uh,
peak common unfortunately
passed away last year. Uh,
one of the great comics that I met
on the way up and just a great guy.
So we're raising money for his kids.
So I want to thank everybody that
came down there last night tonight,
raising funds, doing something
positive, not being an isis,
not being in a hate group.
Write something positive.
Um,
honey,
when I told you I wanted you to be more
social, I should've been more specific.
That's it. Mom pulling up to like
a Klan rally yelling at her son
Timmy. I wish you wouldn't do
that. I really wish you wouldn't.
Could you just stop it? I mean, um,
anyways, I just can't get out of
the vortex of that. So anyways,
I'm all freckles is trying to invest his
fucking money because the government's
taken all of it.
And I'm sitting here trying to buy the
smallest of small little properties here.
So someday when I'm in my
fucking seventies and eighties,
and I don't feel like going out on the
road unless I want to, I don't have to.
You know what I mean? I
don't want to fuck, you know
what I mean? Cause you know,
you,
what goes up comes back down again.
And if I'd start the gentle slide back
down to doing the fucking comedy vault at
Remington's in Boston, when
I'm in my eighties, um,
which unfortunately that room finally
passed away like a year or two ago,
about a year and a half
ago. The comedy vault. Okay.
Legendary room starting in 1993.
Dick Doroty.
How Spike Tobin,
I was on one of the first nights.
They're put together my first five
minutes write down there right next to the
fucking bank vault.
Why am I thinking of that shit?
Because right now I'm trying
to get a loan. All right.
And I have,
I should have perfect fucking credit,
but I don't because I pay off my
credit cards every fucking month.
So when they don't like that,
I paid off my loans early.
They don't like that dings your credit.
They look at that like a loss. Like, Hey,
we were gonna make five grand off this
loan. He paid it off twice as fast,
really made 2,500 bucks.
We lost 2,500 bucks in this guy.
So I've given these guys every fucking
goddamn piece of information they need.
I have the credit, I have the
fucking money. It's a fucking joke.
And then today they come at me.
They want two years of my, uh,
my fucking cell phone bill.
Now I've got to dig through all
of my shit to try and find that.
And I just want to say to them, you can
you just tell me why you need all this?
Oh, these are the new regulations.
Blood. Yes. Yes. And why?
Why are these new regular, why do these
New York regulations exist? Yeah. Well,
I mean that's just something that all,
yeah,
they exist because you guys were
irresponsible with your own country,
Mints Money 10 fucking years ago and you
fucking nuclear economy. I didn't do it.
I'm a responsible fucking guy.
I live within my means.
My checkbook is balanced and now I have
to jump through all these hoops. Why?
Because you guys are greasy,
greedy fucking pieces of shit that gave
every fucking mouth breathing dope.
500 fucking thousand dollars came
walking through your bank doors for good.
Seven,
eight years in the last decade.
Now I got to sit here digging through
shoe boxes. A fucking phone bills.
Okay?
You know, because you're a double
secret probation cause you're a fuck up.
I love how cause they're a fuck up.
All of a sudden it reverts back to me
like now I have to pay for this since
well actually build this you the fact
that they are holding their feet to the
fire like DC,
you know that's a good thing for you
and your money because your money's tied
into the system. I realized that.
I just wish that when you say, hey,
why do I have to do this?
They don't hide behind a regulations.
They should say, well, because
we got so greedy 10 years ago,
the combination of our greed
ended up with the, the fucking,
the cooking of the fucking economy and
old people thought they could retire then
had to continue working right
into their fucking grave.
That's what the fuck we
did with your money. Hence,
we need to see the last fucking two
years. You got damn phone bill. Oh,
we're taking collars. Um, all right.
Let me read a couple of
advertisements here. All right.
All right.
In don't cheat or Indochina,
Indochina, uh, talk about how every man
looks better in his suit. Ah, tell you,
you know what I mean? When I
look at Paul version, I'm like,
this guy's a fucking animal. Yet you
put them in a suit. I'm like, Holy Shit.
I want to hear what that man has to say.
He looks a lot better.
Look at him in that three piece
suit and those Jordan threes. Dude,
the Jordan's phrase with the
three piece suit, dude, um,
Indochino is making it easy
to get perfectly tailored,
a perfectly tailored suit
at an incredible price.
You can choose from hundreds of top
quality fabrics and personalize your suit
just the way you want it,
whether it's for work or a wedding
or another special occasion.
Indochino has suited up hundreds of
thousands of men and are now the largest
made to measure men's
wear brand in the world.
Here's how it works.
You drop your fucking drawers and a
little fella comes in and he measured from
your ball bag down to
your ankle. No, sorry.
Visit a showroom or shop
online@indochino.com pick your fabric.
What do you want next to your bulls?
Choose your customizations from lapels,
lapels to pleats to jacket linings
in more. Submit your measurements,
place your order and wait for a robot of
your exact dimensions to arrive handing
you a suit. And just a few weeks this
week, my listeners can get any premium.
Do you think with the robots take over.
There's going to be like
terrorist robot groups. Oh,
like racist ones hating on the
other ones. The older this week,
my listeners can get any premium
Indochino suit for just 379
dollars@indochino.com when
entering you are are at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for
a made to measure premium suit plus
shipping is free. Oh yeah. You guys
are going to look like the mulch.
You can look like scary and
mu the indochino.com promo
code bar for any premium
suit for $379 and free shipping and
credible deal for a suit that will fit you
better than anything off the rack
ever could. Ah, look who it is,
but it will do me undies.
Me Undies,
your sons into fucking Hitler.
Do to to to be on these beyond the days,
but has pants on and watch
him take his shit lawyer.
He's got a fucking Adolf stash.
What do you need? Nothing rhymes.
I'm fucking sorry. Fuck. I went
with Hitler and mustache stash.
He's got a Hitler fucking stash.
You're a dope. You fucking white trash.
No one cares.
You're not supreme.
You just a bunch of fucking
losers getting sunburns.
Everyone should just ignore them.
I love that whole feeling
that if you ignore them,
that that's just what exactly what they
did when they were in fucking German up.
This is different. This is different.
Okay. You don't have a fleas, aren't you?
That this is different,
right? Isn't it different?
It's completely different.
It's a different scenario. This
country is on top. Germany wasn't,
you know what I mean? If this country
spiraled down in the rankings,
you know like what happened to the
Michigan Wolverines over the last 20 years
where they were,
they were this powerhouse fucking program
and then they just dropped out at site,
flatlined for 15 years. That's when,
that's when they can take hold.
But you know everybody,
everybody's got their fucking,
everybody's walking around with Crocs,
right?
They got the Jags Jagging Zion.
Everybody's got a flat screen TV.
Everybody's putting on weight, like
meets a fucking great country. So they,
nobody hears them.
I don't think,
now I'm just going to shut up me undies.
Okay,
you want to look good in your
underwear? And be comfortable. Right?
But that perfect balance is hard to find.
Yeah. If you're fucking mushrooms fat,
fuck like me. Talk about why me undies
is the best underwear you will ever own.
Feel free to improvise.
Um, listen, I just, if you fucking
want your balls to fill nice and soft,
okay.
Do you want to treat your balls right?
Basically the weak point in the
death star, that is the male body,
which is the balls.
Okay?
Cause I don't give a shit how
many fucking weights you lift,
how many fucking come
full classes you take.
If you look in the other way in a fucking,
I don't care.
A little bunny rabbit is hopping by and
its head comes up and hits you in your
ball bag.
You go and down,
you're tapping out the fights over and
you've got a little bunny sitting on top
of you and he's the new UFC
fighting out of the blue corner.
Me undies will be the most comfortable
pair of underwear you'll ever own.
Made from a sustainably sourced,
naturally soft fabric that is
three times softer than cotton.
Ultimate feel good.
Andries for when you want to feel naked,
not be naked.
What for when you want to feel naked,
not be naked. What? That
doesn't make any sense.
Ultimate feel good undies for when
you want to feel naked. Not Be naked.
Okay, sorry. Uh, for
fellers. Hi me undies.
Diamond seen pouches,
cradles your jewels and gives you stuff
to support it needs without feeling too
tight. Plus it gives it a nice little
outline. If you flash your light on it,
you like, ladies, here's my junk. You
know, if you swing the other ways,
fellows,
like a rhinestone ball bag, boop, boop,
boop right now me and has an I just
realized my mother-in-law's upstairs.
Why don't you my daughter?
I better fucking turn this down.
I just screamed like a
rhinestone ball bag. Oh, Geesh,
right now me and he says,
an exclusive offer for my listeners.
Get 20% off your first pair
and free shipping there. This,
this is a no brainer to try 20% off
free shipping for 100% satisfaction
guarantee. Uh, what are you waiting for?
What are you waiting
for it to get 20% off,
free shipping and their 100% satisfaction
guaranteed in the best and the softest
underwear you'll ever own.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
bird this limited time offer.
This is a limited time offer. So
what are you waiting for? Okay.
Start wearing the best underwear
of your life. It changed my life.
Evidently it's time to get me on
these chain me undies change yours.
It's time to let me on these change.
Yours.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird
right now I've got to get glasses.
All right. Oh, legal zoom,
everybody. It's, it's national.
Make a will month at legal zoom and that
means it's time to take control of your
family and assets.
Preparing for your family's future is
the most important thing you will do this
fucking summer share.
There's a lot of think about what kind
of bear you're going to drink academy and
is she going to buy? You're
going to dazzle your fucking
balls with some jewels,
but other than that,
what happens if our lightening strikes
your ball bag when you're wearing your
dazzle? Rhinestone me
undies, Huh? And your fin,
you die or your nuts are cooked
and you don't feel like a man.
You're too depressed to work. That's why
you need to make a will this month. Okay.
But it's hard. Who wants
to think that hard? Well,
legal zoom created an estate
planning kit to get you going.
Go to legal zoom.com.
Prepare to get your free kit.
You'll get a ton of helpful Info,
plus legal zoom discounts,
all things you need to
stop procrastinating.
Start preparing you for
your family's future.
This is the greatest thing I
ever did. I get a will, right?
So right now you don't give a shit. I'll
fucking walk right up to an alligator.
What do you got buddy? Right? I
don't care. I'm covered. Legal Zoom.
Design A, design this kid to provide
the tools you need all in one place.
Whether a will or a trust
is right for you. I do both.
I have a will and a trust.
All right. Do not revive me.
Light me up. Do not bury me
in the ground. That's it.
Sprinkle my ashes over a dumpster.
Move on.
Um, I should actually say, just put me in
the ground. No coffin. Right there you go.
No coughing. Just let me
fucking decompose. Naturally.
Feed the fucking soil.
He's no dumb. It is that we actually,
you put a box in the ground.
It's so fucking stupid.
You dead. It's over.
But what if I still feel something? Then
you'd still be alive, but you're dead.
You know,
like those people who won't get cremated,
but they're going to sit there and let
somebody fucking drain all the shit out
of him. Take out all your fucking organs
and then fill it up with formaldehyde or
whatever the fuck they do.
Or you can just get it over with.
If you actually feel anything,
you just be like, ah,
like a fucking minute and a half in and
then it's over. What do you die again?
Anyways,
if you have any more questions,
you can always get advice from their
network of attorneys available in all 50
states since legal zooms,
not a law firm. Go to legal
zoom.com/prepare today.
There's no obligation,
just great resources to help you protect
everything you can get during national.
Make a will month. That's
legal, zoom.com/prepare it.
And I have to tell you something.
If you're married and you have kids,
you have to do that. There's so many
guys out there, they're just afraid of,
of thinking about their own mortality.
And I have to tell you, it's, it's a,
it's a weight off of your chest, all
right? Cause when you get to my age,
you're going to see,
unfortunately,
people dying who don't do that stuff.
And how they leave their loved ones is,
is the second tragedy. Um, you know,
so don't fucking do that to
the people you love, all right?
Being dead serious here. Dead
fucking serious, no pun intended.
You've got to fucking do that.
You got to take care of them.
You're going to die fucking
deal with it all right?
And God knows if you've
got a woman in your life,
you're going to die sooner rather than
fucking later with all of this shit that
they do, they just, you know, they
can't help. It's just what they are.
They give they love and they
take this to balance. You know,
everything that they give your kid a,
they take away from you and
then you just slowly died.
This lonely existence in a
room full of other people.
And that is the podcast for
this afternoon. Kidding. Um,
that's everyday was fucking around
today on this podcast. But seriously,
stick your head out the window. You
know, just fucking everybody relax.
Fucking relax.
She's fucking Christ. He can see
these goddamn people. I mean,
they're too fucking stupid. They're too
fucking stupid to brush their teeth.
They're going to run
a country. Um, anyway.
And what does everything always go back
to Germany to this is like jeopardy and
the fucking 1930s. Well,
why isn't it like Russia?
Oh,
why is it that our country in the
fucking 16, 17 and 18 hundreds,
it wasn't exactly a great place to
live for a lot of fucking people. Um,
oh Jesus, now I'm doing it.
I'm talking to the fucking,
I don't know what I'm doing. Am I, am I
ranting and raving now? I have no idea.
All I know is I'm going to be in a good
mood today and I have to do two a days,
two a day. So I don't look
like a freckle doughboy here.
I worked out this morning,
you know,
I did my little half hour on the fucking
elliptical and I threw the weights
around.
Now the most crucial thing is what I eat.
And when I stopped fucking eating.
All right,
so I already got it tonight.
I stopped eating at five o'clock I'm
having a Turkey Patty with the Tabbouleh
Salad,
and then that's it.
And then I have to drink waters
for the rest of the fucking time.
And then to make up for my,
since last night,
I'm going to skip rope for
fucking three rounds. You know,
try to burn off some shit that way.
And maybe that's what I'll do.
I'll do fucking two a days. Is that what
I got to do? I know what I gotta do.
I gotta fucking get out of this
writer's room. That's what I have to do.
Maybe instead of taking a lunch,
maybe I'll,
I'll fucking bringing elliptical into
the office. And when we pitched jokes,
I'll just be on the fucking thing.
And everybody in the writer's
room just takes a turn, you know,
or every time you pitch a joke
and it doesn't get a laugh,
he owed 10 minutes on the
fucking elliptical. You know,
our whole fucking room will look like a,
you know,
they look at the end of the Tour de
France. We just burned so many calories.
Like your body's like eating yourself.
Um,
they'd be going to the table reads by
episodes eight and nine being like,
you know,
it's a funny show,
but Jesus Christ fucking Amaziah
what kind of show we do it here?
Um, they put their heart and soul into
this fucking thing. Um, oh wait a second.
All of a sudden it got loud in my
ears. Oh, I turned it up by accident.
Brushed against it with my forearm
there. All right. Um, hey, by the way,
I got a new band and
I'd been listening to,
and I'm not going to remember the fucking
name of him cause I know my phone.
It's a really weird name for a band.
Let me see.
I'm opening my fucking iTunes,
go to artists.
I know it begins with an a, this is
getting everybody excited, pleased.
Say My alt J.
I downloaded this album called this
is all yours and I fucking love it.
Great album, great album
to chill out to. I listen,
I worked out to what this morning
cause it was early in the morning.
It's kind of fucking, you know, you know,
creepy and mellow and all
that type of stuff. You know,
I guess I knew I was going to get
on the fucking s scale, but um,
I never heard of them. And Josh, Adam
Meyers from the goddamn comedy jam,
the actually when I was
on the road he goes, Hey,
I'm going to go see this band
tonight. Uh, all Jay and Mike, what?
I thought it was a Typo.
It's a l t lowercase dash capital j.
Uh,
I really enjoyed them.
And once again,
you math has a new album coming out
next month. Alright, that is it.
Please listen to the music.
Little interlude here before we give you
another half hour of greatest hits from
a Thursday afternoon
podcasts from a Thursday,
from a Thursday that went by on a Thursday
that you didn't even pay attention to.
All right. That's it. God bless you.
Thank you for not being a Nazi and a,
I'll have a good weekend. You can
sit. I'll talk to you on Monday.
And the Nice
[inaudible] far
trumpets,
the suit of Patty,
they say
your son.
No
cause no body is
dry
walleyes.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Barr and this is the
Monday morning podcasts from Monday,
August 17th,
2007 2009 why can't I have a decent date,
right?
I actually,
this is the second time I started the
podcast because I always just start it and
then I go to say the date and I
realize I don't know what the date is.
So I'm sick of doing that.
Like I just did that and I fucked
up the date and I was like,
I do this every time.
People are gonna think it's a gimmick,
like always deliberately fucking
up to date. So I just hit stop.
I hit a race and I started over again
and I fucked up the year something wrong
with my brain. You know what
it was? Cause it was the 17th.
Then my brain was thinking seven. So
then when I went to say, the year,
I say said 2007, in case you're
wondering case you're wondering,
I'm anyways, I'm actually, uh,
it's Sunday when I'm doing
this podcast because, uh,
if you listen to this east
coast time in the morning,
I'm on an airplane right now. And
uh, I just got a bunch of shit to do.
So I figured, uh, I'm not doing anything
today. Why not bang out a podcast,
you know,
anybody can go out and Atlanta and hang
out with another human being. You know,
it takes a real secure fucking loser,
okay. To, uh, you know,
still being his fucking hotel
bed at what the fuck time is it?
1220 in the afternoon.
Ah,
Jesus Christ watching the,
um,
whatever the fuck golf major.
This is the PGA.
I'm actually betting against tiger
woods kind of have this ongoing a bet.
I keep betting against tiger
woods with a another comic,
a friend of mine who is of
African persuasion, you know,
basically, cause I've kind of not
been watching baseball lately. Uh,
I've been trying to pick up new sports
and the only way for me to get into golf
is to have stupid ass bets. So I
figure I'll bet against not only while,
I bet against tiger woods,
I will bet against tiger
woods with another black dude.
And I will, uh, you know, just
to make an interesting, you know,
say dumb shit, like golf's a white man's
game. Um, I'm betting on Ernie els.
You know what?
I actually won in the fucking masters,
I bet on Phil Mickelson and I won that
one cause he beat tiger woods. And then,
I don't know, I got busy and I
could've won another, you know,
we bet like 25 bucks a major,
I could have won the US Open and I
also could have won the fucking, uh,
that went over there in
England and I blew those off
and I think I'm going to lose today.
It's weird. I'm betting against tiger,
but you know, my money is, but I'm
actually rooting for him, you know?
Is that exciting now? I don't think
it is either. Anyways, let's, uh,
let's plow ahead here.
I'm going to fucking bad mood.
I had a really had a
really bad show last night.
Now I had a bad show.
I went up there and I did this whole
bit on Michael Vick coming back and it
killed and everybody was having a great
time. And then at the end of my set, this,
this woman comes up to me and,
uh,
you like when someone's going to insult
you, you know, rather than have an,
I'm going to insult you.
Look on their face.
They come up and they have an ear to ear,
like Erik Estrada Grin on their face.
That's what she was doing. And she was
just going to like, hi. Hey, how are you?
Yeah, yeah. That whole thing
about Michael Vick. Yeah. Yeah.
Did you really believe that? Is that
really how you feel? Yeah, and I,
I immediately knew. I'm like, Oh
God, this is a dog lover. Here we go.
So I was just like a, okay
ma'am. All right. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry I didn't like the show.
Uh, you know, they're just jokes.
If you want to take them seriously,
go ahead and take them seriously.
And then she just gave here.
Yeah. Yeah. Cause you stayed.
Me and she statements are really ignorant.
I just say you should know that
she was like nodding and smiling.
You stay me through really ignorant. It's
like first of all, why are you smiling?
You know, I I, that was the most annoying
thing. Not that she came up to me.
I mean it's my own God damn fault.
I fucking not only do I go on stage
and I say a bunch of stupid shit,
but then I stand there
like an idiot selling DVDs.
I'm opening myself to somebody coming up
to me and telling me to go fuck myself.
I don't have a problem with that.
That comes with being a fuck can shit at
who sells DVDs at the end of his show.
All right.
So I totally could have avoided that.
So I'm not complaining about that.
What I'm complaining about is people
who are telling you to go fuck yourself,
but they're smiling. Like, is that
supposed to like mind? Fuck me.
Like I'm gonna like I'm not even going
to notice what you're saying. Okay. Like,
wow, it sounds like she's telling me
to go fuck myself, but she's smiling.
Maybe I'm hearing this wrong.
And then she's like,
your statements are really ignorant. And
she's nodding like, you know what I mean?
Like that bugs bunny shit. Like remember
that when he, when he would be like, no,
you know they've gotta be
like, yes, no, yes, no.
And then at some point
he would switch and go,
he would switch over his fucking
argument than the other guy would end up
arguing bugs bunny's argument. That's
what the fuck she was trying to do to me,
you statements are really ignorant and
she's like nodding like I'm going to be
like, yes, my statements were
ignorant. So I said, lady,
so basically what you're telling me is
because I don't agree with your point of
view, that that makes me ignorant. And,
and then she pulls this, this thing.
She goes, I'm actually a member
of the humane society. All right.
You know,
first of all,
who the fuck breaks out credits during
an argument? You know what I mean?
She says it right. I'm, I'm a
member of the humane society, right?
Like it's supposed to be like this.
Dun, Dun, Dun fucking moment. Oh Shit.
Are you a member of the humane society?
Good Lord.
How many years of college did
it take to get that Holy Shit?
Did you have to go through medical
school to become a member of the fucking
humane society? I actually, if
I have the second was like, wow,
I actually thought that she was on the
board of the humane society. First of all,
I don't even know what the
fucking humane society is.
Humane sounds like Humana to me,
like you're into people and evidently
it isn't. You're into fucking animals.
So I'm sitting here later on tonight,
I'll fucking annoyed with this lady.
This lady is Jerry Lewis would say,
right?
I'm all fucking annoyed with this
lady thinking like a man. I'm like,
wait a minute.
She's a member of the humane society.
You know, I was a fucking
member of, uh, the fuck is that,
that that day.
Now of course I can't remember.
You know what I'm taking right
now is how fucked up my brain is.
I'm thinking a apocalypse now.
Amnesty International.
I know it was an a because I,
for some reason I thought there was a pa,
I was a member of Amnesty International
for like, like two, three years,
you know, that was against torture
and people around the world.
And he and I became a member.
I gave him 25 bucks.
I went on the Internet
and I gave him 25 bucks.
I have no fucking idea what
they did with the money.
I don't know if they stopped
someone from getting tortured.
I don't know if they just took
that money and they both, you know,
a couple of them went out to a movie.
Yeah. 25 bucks. We go to the matinee can,
I was probably eight bucks each set up
for some popcorn to two tickets and a
popcorn. Come on and do it. We're
not going to stop torture. Um,
so that's what I did. So go, let
me go on the fucking Internet.
Let me look up this, this, uh,
this humane society. And uh,
so I went to it humane
society.org and sure enough,
this is all you have to
do to become a member.
It's $19 a month or
whatever you can afford.
So I could give these fucking people a
dollar a month and then I too could walk
around and be a total fucking cunt and
then throw out my credit that I am a
member of the humane society.
And you know what?
I'm going to fucking join
the humane society at $1.
So the next time I do
this Michael Vick bit,
when one of these fucking psycho people
comes up to me having memory of the
humane society, Oh shit. You
know what? So Am I. Holy Shit.
I can't believe I didn't see it,
the meeting. Oh, that's right.
Neither one of us go to him.
Yeah,
there is no fucking meetings.
A member of you made society.
You want to fucking,
I can't put,
she threw that out like she was on fucking
like she just did the tonight show.
I'm the head of NBC.
You will never get a show on my network.
That's the way the fuck she was saying it.
God dammit.
It got worse. It got worse. So you
know me, someone's being a con to me.
No one can out count me.
So you know,
I'm actually upset with myself
because I allowed her to make me mad.
As you can tell, considering it's
fucking 12 hours later and I'm still on,
I'm talking about it alone in my hotel
room with the drapes, pulled clothes.
This is how I always do it on the road.
Fucking sit around like Howard Hughes. Um,
yeah. So then she goes, uh, you know,
I remember the human or humane society and
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And I said,
look,
okay,
okay.
You know, I just, I don't want to do,
why do people take comedy seriously?
Those are stand up comedy
show. I'm not doing it. I'm,
I can't even begin to tell you
guys how many times am I act.
I say that I'm a moron. You guys listen
to my podcast. You know I'm a moron.
Actually,
some people don't.
I had some guy send me this fucking email
this week on bill for the love of God.
Stop talking about banks. You
sound like a moron. Read this shit.
What do you mean read this shit?
That is goes against everything that I am.
I don't fucking read. And Like I love
how you talked about those banks.
You sounded like a moron. And what?
When I talked about the other shit,
I sounded intelligent.
Yeah.
So fucking podcast. Just
stand up back. I don't,
I don't, ah, all right. You know
what? Look at it. Here I go again.
I'm allowing myself to get fucking
worked up about this shit. So anyways,
couple more back and forths go.
And then she just realizes
that I don't give a fuck.
I said something like, well, you
know what you should do ma'am,
is what I always say when somebody just
says that they don't, uh, you know,
enjoy me and they just want
to keep telling me how much
they don't enjoy my act.
What I always say to him, I was like,
well, you know what you should do.
You should never come to one of
my shows again. That'll show me.
So then she finally realized is that
I don't give a shit about our humane
society fucking credit that she
basically purchased, you know,
it's, you know what a, again,
being a member of the humane society is
less respectful than when they give some
famous person an honorary degree,
because at least the celebrity didn't
fucking pay for it. He didn't go,
didn't go to Syracuse university.org
and give $19 so he could be like,
I have an honorary degree from
fucking Syracuse University, you know?
So anyways, so that's why I say so.
Well, this lady, all right, you know,
you know what you should do. You should
never come to one of my shows again.
That'll show me.
And at this point there's kind of some
people around me that are starting to
laugh. So then this girl just, you know,
who's a member of the humane society
because she cares so much than just,
she just starts going from my juggler.
She goes, yeah, well, you know,
smiling and nodding, right. This is creepy
fucking smile. And this whole time too,
she's got a clump of
lipstick on her upper lip.
She's one of these girls you could tell
was hot when she was in her twenties and
now she's doing,
the worst thing that you can do is
you're trying to hang onto it, you know,
so she looks like,
you know,
one of the real housewives
of fucking Tupelo,
Mississippi or wherever the fuck she's
from. Right. And she's calling, uh,
she's gone out. Yeah, yeah. Well you're
doing great, right? You're doing great.
You're here at the punchline. Hi, you're
doing great. And I'm like, yeah, you know,
shows kind of seem to be selling well,
she goes, now, yeah, it's great. You know?
Yeah, you were on Hbo and
now you're here, you know,
and it's like, lady, so
are you your ear too?
And you fucking paid to come here to
watch me. What is your fucking point?
And she's like, and I didn't
pay, I didn't pay whatever.
And then she'd said something to the,
if she started talking really,
then she did that, that, that,
that thing. You know what,
how women have confrontations.
Like that was what they do is they
stop talking to you and then they start
talking to their friend really loudly
about you and she starts getting that guy
a fucking piece of shit.
The funny thing was was she couldn't have
been more than five feet away from me.
And she's yelling at
[inaudible] pizza is yet,
and then that's when I told
her, you know, lady, you know,
I really didn't want to tell you this,
but you got a big,
he got something on your upper lip
and I didn't want to bring it up,
but now you're being a jerk. And
she goes, it's lipstick. I Dunno,
I don't even what happened after that,
that point I was actually mad.
And, um, and I dunno,
I kind of blamed the whole evening on a
not drinking if you can fucking believe
it, you know, cause I
usually enjoy doing the road.
And now this is my third weekend that
I've done where I have not had a drop of
alcohol.
And now I finally understand why
comedians want to get off the road.
I never realized how many fucking morons
there are out here because I was drunk
and I was part of the problem.
But now, now I'm sober.
I'm like, God, I'm talking about myself.
Like I'm actually a fucking alcoholic.
I'm not. I'm just so fucking
lonely loser. And that's what I do.
I have a couple of beers,
talk a little shit.
That's it built denial. That's the
first fucking stage of it, VJ saying,
oh, what a shot. Jesus
Christ from the French.
Oh,
you know what that was from yesterday.
Don't you fucking hate like when you
do that, when you're watching sports,
you ever done that in a sports bar?
You looked away for a second.
He didn't realize it was a replay from a
month. Again, somebody hits a home run,
you're like, ah, fuck it. And
you're like the only guy, not dude,
that was from my last Tuesday, they were
playing the rangers. They're like, oh,
I thought, I thought there
was, I thought that was so,
now you want another case at dia.
Um,
you know what I like about Vj Singh?
Ali's fucking douchebags nowadays a days
they're trying to bring back that rat
pack swagger and you can't,
you can't do it all right.
And the only guy,
I dunno why,
I dunno why he can't wear shirts
the way they wore shirts back then.
You can't wear that fucking little
bing Crosby hat the way they wore it.
I don't know why.
I have no fucking idea why frank and why
Dean and Sammy and all those guys look
so low, so fucking smooth. I have no
idea why, but I was watching this,
uh, golf the other day. I got
to admit fucking Vj Singh,
he's got a little swagger to him,
you know, plus he said that, uh,
that hateful shit against women,
you know,
which really lines up
with their generation.
Remember that back then once they just
like beating their women with a mop
handle every time they didn't have
their raw roast beef and mashed potatoes
ready or some shit. I Dunno
what's, so anyways, I've had a uh,
yeah,
I'm trying to figure out why that
lady bug me so much. Last night
I, you know, she was just, I dunno, I,
I felt I was pissed at myself that I got
mad and then I was also mad at myself
die stand there like a
fucking idiot selling DVDs.
MMM.
You know, I don't know. It really
just made me want to be like,
you know what,
why don't I just go to the green room
after shows and I'll do my shows and then,
you know, whatever. I'll get
an email and you know, I dunno,
you fucking sit there dance around like
a monkey boy for 50, 50, 55 minutes.
I bet you even did an hour of that show.
I can't remember.
Then they have somebody come up to you,
just talk and say that you're a
piece of shit because of a joke.
And then there are a woman,
so you can't like, you know,
you know it was funny
was she was with a guy.
So the whole thing time
she's given me shit.
It's like I don't want to lose
so I'm giving her shit back.
But at the same time I got to keep my
eye on the dude and also like not go too
far because then I got like a
physical confrontation with the dude,
which I don't want to have.
I'm 41 years old.
Last time I had a fight 35 that was
when my brother and a red roof inn.
That's an entirely different story.
And that doesn't count either because
your brother's going to stop at some point
cause he has to answer to your dad.
You know, I can't fucking remember.
Right. I ain't not tough
sky. I tell jokes. Right.
So I don't want to get into this guy.
You know,
it was funny the entire time the guy had
his back to me and he was trying to get
the woman out of the club.
Okay.
And that's the exact kind of guy
who goes out with a woman like that.
And vice versa.
If it's a loud mouth Douche bag guy,
they always have a little mousy girl
because nobody who actually would speak
their mind would ever tolerate dating
somebody like that man or a woman.
They will be like, are you out of your
mind? Are you out of your mind right now?
You know, it's a joke. This guy's telling
jokes or whatever. You made your point.
Now you're just gonna stand
here screaming. I Dunno.
I Dunno. It was a fucked up
night. Then I had the next show.
I'm onstage and I'm doing my act and
I'm having a great time. And you know,
I told the story about the woman I call
direct contact and I felt like I got
that out and everything was going great.
Then all of a sudden this, uh, this, this,
uh, this lady just walks up to the
stage. I'm in the middle of my acts.
She's like, can you, can you, can you say
happy birthday? And my friend had there,
it was like,
lady,
could you act like maybe I'm fucking in
the middle of doing a show at some point.
I know it was just, it was a fuck. It
was a weird, it was just a weird night.
And then after that, then I went
over to the club to 90 next door.
Um, as I always end up
doing, and this time,
this is the first time I went in there
and I wasn't drinking and I realized how
fucked up that place was. It was
just, dude came up to me, right.
And this whole week I've really been
having a difficult time understanding some
of these, uh, who, people
who live outside of Atlanta,
they're fucking accents this,
uh,
I'm standing there talking to a couple
of people from the club and this guy just
comes up to me. He's like, we'll,
yeah.
I'm like, what? He's like, will
he sticking his hand down? And um,
I thought he was saying like, will you
like, he was starting to sentence like,
will you stop standing there?
Will you buy me a drink?
I know what the fuck he was going to.
Evidently he was saying his name,
he was introducing himself, his
name was William, but he's got will,
will, and I was like, what? I don't,
but this is one of those bars.
Everybody's, every other person seemed
like they were on fucking coke. And uh,
I don't know. This is just
Peter and out. I don't know.
I'm just fucking,
I've had enough and I usually do Thursday
through Saturday and something fucked
up happening this weekend when I'm
doing Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
And somebody asked me this
question last week, like, uh,
asked me if Sunday was a
depressing day on the road. Um,
I don't know if you listen to my past
podcasts, I think I answered that.
Yes it is. Sunday is the
fucking worst. You know,
two shows Friday,
three shows Saturday in know the big peak
and you want to fucking leave and then
you got to hang around the entire fucking
day to do one more 50 minutes set.
And then you've got a fly in on Monday,
which is the fucking worst. You know,
I like flying on Sundays, you
know, flying across the country,
everybody's still asleep.
They go into church, you know,
they're waking up from a hangover
finishing that last slice of dominoes.
I don't know what they're doing,
but they're not on the road driving.
So when I land at the airport,
I just grabbed my shit at,
jump in a cab and I'm fucking
back at my place. You know,
you fly back on a Monday, the ups trucks,
the Fedex guys are out there, right?
Fucking homeless people laying in the
streets. It's just fucking horrific.
So anyways,
I had such a great week too.
I had a great week. You know, one
of the people listens to my podcast,
works over at Cap,
the capitol records place,
and they invited me over there to go
on a tour, which I did this past week.
And I got to tell you was it is the,
was the the greatest tour of
anything I've ever taken ever.
Do you remember if Geraldo Rivera,
when he did al Capone's vault and
everybody thought it was going to be the
greatest fucking thing ever. I remember
how great you thought it was going to be.
Like what the fuck is
going to be in that safe?
And you're like there's no
way this is going to suck.
And it just didn't live up to it.
Whatever your expectations of that
where this was 20 times that it was
unbelievable. The guy
basically explained it. Uh,
and I'm saying the guy,
cause I don't use people's names on this,
he was basically explaining that the
capital records building is basically a
functioning museum,
meaning that there's a bunch of shit that
they're still using that really should
be in a museum.
I walked into the room where Frank
Sinatra sang all those songs.
Luck be a lady, Dean Martin, all them,
they had nat king Cole's piano and they
had this little metal chair like yeah
that's Frank Sinatra's
chair and I'm looking
at it and I'm like that's not fucking
Frank Sinatra's chair that looks like it
should be in an ips class.
That was like one of those science room
classes and later on in the tour he was
showing all these black and white photos.
Cause I guess back in the day,
the capitol records label had their own
photographer and they took all these
fucking pictures.
And by the way,
frank and dean never
looked bad at any moment.
They want a picture of Dean Martin eating
a bowl of soup and he looked like a
fucking million bucks.
But anyways,
then you look at the photos
and there's that fucking chair.
They had a microphone over
there that said Frank. Oh yeah,
that's Frank Sinatra's microphone.
And then they just use it.
You know,
I gotta just fight.
Absolutely fucking blew me everything.
And I can't even like they had like
the masters of like a, the band,
you know that group.
Like they just had them laying,
not like laying in the corner. They were
going to be doing something with them.
And then I fuckin actually got to hold
it in my hand. A master. It was, it was,
I don't know if you're a music geek,
that is the,
that it was the place to go. And not
to mention later on that afternoon,
one of my favorite drummers of all time,
Steve Jordan was recording with,
uh,
some huge artists.
Okay.
And they actually,
you know what sucked was,
they had already recorded his drum shit.
So he was going to be doing, I get some,
some percussion shit and all I
wanted to see was his kit set up in,
in the, uh, in the studio.
That's all I wanted to see.
But I fucking missed it by a day.
But other than than that,
then I got to go on top of the building,
you know,
like I was fucking dice clay and
Ford Fairline unbelievable view.
It was, it was the greatest fucking
thing I've ever done. Um, and I know it.
And if I was more articulate, I could
explain how awesome it was. So, uh,
I want to thank everyone over at capitol
records for being so fucking cool.
That was the greatest tour of
anything I've ever taken. And, uh,
do you ever want to come to one of
my shows? If you bring 40 friends,
I will still hook you up. That's how
great that tour was. So there we go.
Look at me. I'm bringing it
around to something positive.
Half the fucking Twat from the
humane society. Oh wait a minute.
I can donate by phone.
You want to hear me do this?
Let's see how easy it is to fucking
join the humane society of America.
You think they answer on Sunday?
Do they make their people work on Sunday?
That's not very humane.
Is it? Three, nine,
three nine. Alright, let's
see if we can do this.
Oh wait,
I'm gonna have to give my credit card
number over and you guys can hear this
wedding. Oh wait, they're saying the
number has been changed or disconnected.
Oh fuck you. Computer woman.
I'm joining the humane society.
I cannot fucking wait for the next dog
lover to come up to taking that joke.
Seriously. I'm a member of
the humane society. So Am I.
I have your credit too,
ma'am.
And I got it in the time that it
takes to write a check. So stand down.
All right.
And why don't you blot your fucking
lips before you walk out of the fucking
house? I'm good. Phil Mickelson.
[inaudible] got love about Phil Mickelson.
That guy always goes for the pin.
You have an order set shit.
He just doesn't give a fuck.
And then he for Putts, the guys
aren't into. And then e four plots.
I don't know. So anyways, let me,
let's get to the podcast questions
this week by phone is vibrating.
Um, you know, it's weird.
I have not drank and so long and I still
feel hung over cause I stayed up till
four in the morning last night. I couldn't
go to sleep. I was so fucking pissed.
All right, here we go. Let's get to some
of the stuff. Okay. A youtube videos.
If you would like a laugh this week for
some reason, I only have one of them.
I don't know why. I know I got
more, I don't know. I get busy.
I fly around sometimes I fuck up. This
is actually a cool video watch. Ah, it's,
it's snuff box boyfriends scenes,
s n u f,
F snuffbox boyfriends scenes.
And uh,
I think you'll enjoy that.
I got a couple of other ones,
but people will kind of send me stuff
that I just feel like they're just classic
, um, youtube videos. Like who
hasn't seen that woman who you know,
who she stomps the grapes,
you know,
she's having that competition and then
she falls out of the thing and then she,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
You know, cause you've got
the wind knocked out of her.
And I know that sounds like I'm
doing a fucked up impression,
but that's exactly what she sounds like.
And if you don't believe me a let's,
let's fucking bring up that
video right now. Shall We?
Let's see a stomp stomping grapes.
Let's see if that'll work. Did that
just fucking work? Of course it didn't.
I really don't like typing
with one hand stomping grapes.
And I'm telling you it's literally,
yeah.
Oh, oh, oh
here we go. Here we go.
Listen how she does it.
Oh, that's done is right here.
These buckets are filled with grace.
Jess, fall off the fucking
thing. Shut up. Shut up.
All right,
here they go.
It's like a tight, here we
go. So what's The dip? Sorry,
I'm trying to fast forward to this.
Shut up.
Why can't you fast forward these videos
better and now it won't fucking play.
God dammit.
You know what am I gonna have to
start this podcast over again?
This is so fucking horrific.
Go play.
Here we go. There we
go. Uh, you know what?
Go Fuck yourself a plate later on.
Why the damn thing's to load up.
All right.
You don't,
I feel like right now I feel like one of
those news guys who I just threw it to
the field and then the story's not there
and I got to stand there smiling and
I'm like, oh, okay. Now there's nothing
on the teleprompter for me to read,
so I feel like a fucking moron. All
right, let's go to ask bill. Hey Bill,
I want to be a standup.
My friends say that I am funny.
I wrote down about five minutes of Shit.
I thought it was funny and I did a
little stand up back to my brother.
He laughed and said it was great.
I have dangerously low
self esteem in myself.
And the fact,
uh,
that I don't usually like to laugh at
myself when I'm writing jokes by myself.
I usually laugh at a joke I tell when
I say in front of people and I realized
how crazy it sounded.
I live in a small town so there's
not really any standup clubs.
There is a place called the coffee
connection, which has an open Mike.
There I am a little nervous to go because
I don't want to bomb and completely
destroyed my confidence.
I have to actually become a comedian.
I'm not afraid to talk in front of people.
I just don't want to fuck up in
front of other people. But um,
here is where a bigger problem
comes in at my high school.
They have a talent show around
the end of the school year.
If I got up there and did shit
and didn't make anybody laugh,
everyone that didn't know me at the
school would think I'm some dusty cunt.
That just was up there for
the attention. I think. Uh,
I would just use the classic,
I was just fucking around.
I wasn't even serious line,
but inside I would still feel like shit.
Do you have any advice that could
help me? Yes, I do. All right.
First of all, having low self esteem
and can sort of hating yourself.
You have the foundation for
becoming a comedian. Um,
you got to give yourself permission
to suck and you got to give yourself
permission to grow in the beginning,
which means you have to go out and you
have to perform in front of people that
you don't know. The last fucking
thing that you want to do,
not knowing how to do stand up would be
to go on in front of your entire high
school.
I mean,
okay,
that, you know what maybe at
that takes that right there.
The fact that you're even
considering doing that,
you have way more balls than
I ever had at your age. Okay?
So you're already fucking ahead of me.
And not to mention that you're still in
high school and you're already starting
it. So I didn't start doing stand
up till I was 23, almost 24.
So you're way ahead of the game.
There's no fucking reason to put yourself
into that situation unless you feel
confident. You know, if you
feel confident, you feel
like you're going to destroy,
who knows? You might bang one of them
fucking cheerleaders there. But, uh,
but then that would probably boost
yourself confidence. It'd be like, well,
maybe I'm not a Douche and then you just
get some regular job and you'd never
get into show business.
Um,
but I digress now you've gotta give
you gotta Oh, um, you know, something.
I did stand up and for the first year I
didn't tell and none of my friends even
knew I was doing it.
I think one of them knew and
nobody saw me for the first year.
I wouldn't let anybody cut my,
my family knew that I was doing it and
I would not let any of them come out to
see me do it. And, um,
I didn't let my parents first saw me.
I started in March of 1992 and my parents
first came out to see me in March of
1993 and I've always been
blown away by comedians.
Um,
they'll go there first time ever on
stage and they invite everyone from their
office to come down to the place where
they work to watch them do stand up.
And I'm just like,
dude,
do you realize what it's going to be like
if you fucking bomb and you have to go
to work the next day? I mean,
why would you set yourself up?
I mean it's just, I dunno. So what
I would do, my advice to you is,
is first of all,
don't worry about having a low confidence
or low self esteem or whatever the
hell it is. You don't have
to worry about that. You'll,
your confidence will build as you do it.
But what you have to do is just,
you just go out and go do open mikes.
You'll,
you'll get in the click
of other open makers,
you'll make some friends and then you
become like this little platoon, you know,
and it's like you against the world.
Okay.
And everybody's going to bomb all every,
all your Oprah micro friends are
gonna bomb. You're going to bomb.
You're all going to fucking do it.
It sucks.
But it's the best stories you'll ever
tell in your life and later on in your
career, you're gonna look back and tell
some stories. I mean, I'll tell you,
you know,
it would be a hell of a fucking story is
if you went up in front of your entire
fucking high school
and you ate your balls.
I mean that's some shit like later
on in your career if you, you know,
if he was starring in a movie and you
needed a panel story to tell on Letterman
or fucking Conan, I mean that
would be a hell of a one to tell.
So that's,
I mean I,
it's hard for me to tell you what to
do as far as whether you should do that
high school show or not. All
I can go is with, with my gut.
The fact I got like
scared reading your email,
thinking of just putting myself in your
position of like just picturing myself
at 1718 if I ever went on in front of
my high school and try to tell jokes,
I mean I probably,
that would have been a bucket of blood
above me and would have poured down on me
just like in that movie, Carrie
would have been bad. You know,
I got to met halfway through that.
I wouldn't, I just thought like,
what if I killed the,
you know,
say you're like a junkie. He just
keep fucking chasing it. All right,
so don't worry about it man.
Just fucking have fun. Go Out,
sign up for some open mics and just do
it in bars where show in football games
and no one's looking at you and
you just learn, get tough that way.
That's what I would do. You know? And
if you want to do the high school show,
by all means fucking go for it.
Personally, I wouldn't do it, but that,
but coming from a place of fear,
so you know, if you got the balls,
go ahead and do it.
But if you do it,
I want to hear the results so
please email me back. All right.
But other than that, don't
worry about, you know,
second guessing your material and all
that stuff and thinking stuff sucks.
That's just a part of it in the beginning.
Okay.
If you think you're awesome
when you first start out,
you usually end up being a hack,
you know, and you're out there,
you know what's deal with local jerks
and I'm fucking great. All right.
I hope that helped you out. Okay. All
right. Any, uh, next question, Bill. Um,
I want to ask you about how you felt
about parents taking their kids on planes.
Recently I had a flight to Denver back
from Los Angeles. Not a long flight,
but I was absolutely exhausted and
looking forward to the two hours of not
talking to people and
hoping to maybe catch a nap.
I had no such luck on young couple with
their two year old Brat set behind me.
And proceeded to let their kid kick the
back of my seat and screamed repeatedly.
It was awful. I don't blame the kid. Two
year old kids, they, they kick and scream.
That's what they do.
But the kids' parents did nothing to
control the child other than saying,
you shouldn't do that. What really
pissed me off was that we were,
when we were landing, they were asking
their child what he wanted for dinner.
And this is written in capital letters.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Two year olds don't get options.
12 year olds don't get options.
20 year olds don't get fucking options
if they're living in your house and
you're paying for everything.
As we were getting off the plane,
I was hoping these people would have
the decency to apologize for their kid
kicking the back of my seat.
But of course they didn't.
I've thought about telling these
people that they ought to both get a,
they ought to both get fixed because
they were absolute assholes and all they
were doing was raising another absolute
asshole and adding one more to the
fucking population.
Um,
but I kept my mouth shut because people
like that see nothing wrong with their
behaviors. So what's the fucking
point anyway? Have you ever,
have you ever experienced, had an
experienced slice like this? Um,
did you think about saying something? Did
you actually say something? All right.
Uh, great question. I
gotta be honest with you.
When I'm on it plane
and a kid starts crying,
I don't know why I can't explain it,
but it makes me laugh and it makes me
laugh watching other people get fucking
annoyed because, uh, I don't know.
Somewhere along the line I just sorta
let go of that. It's like, look,
these people, they have kids just like
you said, they can't control them. Um,
and that's it.
But I will tell you this,
if you have a kid and
it's in the fucking thing,
cause it two year old, it's not a
person yet, it's a fucking thing.
The fucking thing is kicking the back
of the seat of the person in front of me
in front of you. You have to do
something about that. All right?
They got little short little
fucking legs at that point.
All you gotta do is just scoot him
back and they won't be able to,
they won't be able to, to,
to kick the back of the seat.
Now I might be fucking ignorant here cause
never had a little two year old thing.
And I might be over simplifying this
because I really have sympathy for,
uh, for, for people in that
situation. Man, I don't what,
what are you supposed to do?
I mean, in a perfect world,
you could just knock the kid out, but
you wouldn't want to do that. It's a kid.
You can't punch your kid.
I mean you can,
but then you'd have to talk to somebody
from the fucking humane society. A wow,
I didn't know what the fuck I'm saying.
You know what I mean? Perfect world.
You could just tie him to the seat.
They would move,
but you'd psychologically
damaged with them, um, you know,
damage the kid and then you've got to
live with them for at least another 16
years before he fucking moves
on to community college. So, um,
have I ever said anything? No, I
have never said anything. I wouldn't,
I would never say something
like, you know, you know,
tick. Do you understand that?
I also like when the planes landing,
you know like when you ears
a pop and like little kids,
they don't know what to do.
They don't know what to do.
But I've definitely given some people,
some not even like what the fuck
I give him that look like really?
You just kind of let the kids sit there.
And this is another thing too,
if your kid is freaking out,
if you're just making a fucking effort,
even if you can't stop the
kid from freaking the fuck
out, just make an effort.
This is weird. I'm gradually agreeing
with this person more and more.
Just make a fucking effort.
That's all.
When people are just sitting there
and letting the kid cry. I mean,
I don't know if they're
doing an experiment because
I've heard like if you pick
a baby up every time it
cries and it learns, okay,
all I have to do is cry and
then I get this comfort. Um,
if you're trying to retrain them, I don't
know if you're going to retrain him.
Could you do it at home?
I think they should sedate kids. There
you go. Yeah, I just said that, you know,
just come in with the fucking,
have one of those fucking world war two
psycho doctors just come in with an old
fashioned needle.
You just drug them up or maybe they could
have like a fucking a glassed in area.
Do you guys ever have that?
Like the crying Roman church,
you'd put your kid's way in the back
and they just be behind glass, you know,
so they wouldn't interrupt the priest
scaring the living shit out of you that
you're going to be going to hell.
Maybe they should have that
down by the luggage. Um,
anyways, uh, so no, I've
never said anything. Yes, I've
wanted to say some things,
but um, you know, by the end of it,
you know when you're actually going to
say something, the flight's over anyways.
And uh, I had some part of flying,
isn't it? Some kids screaming anyways.
All right. Um, what am I moving on
to the next part of the podcast?
Oh wait, is this video loaded up yet?
Remember my impression? Oh, oh, oh,
okay.
Here we go.
Here we go
on a whole day.
Oh Wow. I was up. I was,
oh,
I can't read.
See, I told you. Oh, oh, oh.
You know what that was,
that's the first time she ever
got the wind knocked out of her,
so she didn't know what to do. That's
what I sounded like when I was five.
The first time that happened to me,
and the first thing you learned is when
you get the wind knocked out of view,
is to shut the fuck up. Because
every, anyone, if you try to talk,
when you get the wind knocked out of you,
that's what the fuck you sound like.
So you learned afterwards. Once you
get your breath back, you're like, wow,
I really sounded like a fucking
idiot as I was going. Do you know,
you just fucking,
can anybody explain that phenomenon?
What is that and why?
No matter how hard you're
trying to breathe in,
does your breath keep exhaling
or just pushing out? You know,
it's like when you,
when you, uh, he's like,
you're having a dry heave but you're not
puking, you know, just for those of you,
like, you know, I dated a girl one
time, she was like 27 years old.
She'd never had the wind knocked
out of her in her life. Um,
which I thought was one of the most
adorable things I'd ever heard. Yeah.
It was like she was living under glass
or something. But anyways, uh, why is,
you know, do you, how many fucking
times that happen to me as a kid?
That was like what we did. Me and
my boy, you know, had four brothers.
That's what we did as a kid.
That's, that's what you did.
And your brother wasn't paying attention.
You didn't have to do it hard.
That was great. You just
give him a fucking rep right
in the stomach and the kid,
fuck this. Ho, um,
does all the wind literally
go out and why can't you just,
why can't you just breathe in?
Why am I acting like you guys,
a fucking doctors? Why this isn't just
a bunch of truckers. Just forget it.
Don't even, you know what,
I want somebody to attempt,
you know what half the people who are
going to fucking answer this question.
I'm going to do exactly what I'm going
to do at the end of this fucking podcast,
which is just look it up and then give
me the Wikipedia reason. All right,
here we go. Here's some questions
for the week. Um, Bill, um,
on a different not that's
what someone just wrote.
I think they wanted to say
no to on a different not,
I was wondering what did you think
of the song Baba O'reilly by the WHO?
I recently started listening to rock
music and I thought that this song was
incredible. Is it? Or I am or am I
just some dumb fuck no, you're not.
You're a young kid and you're discovering
the WHO and they are the shit. Um,
I would get who's next? I would get a
live at Leeds. Start with that. Just,
just surf the Internet. They've got
some great shit. Um, dear bill. Ha.
How much drinking do you
typically do during the week? Um,
you're out on the road all of the
time working places that serve booze.
And it seems like it would be tempting
to drink pretty often out of boredom,
boredom and loneliness. I think
I already, to answer this,
at least I could see myself doing
that if I were a traveling comedian.
Is it tough to avoid being a
lush? Ah, yeah. It kinda is.
You basically become an alcoholic out of,
uh,
like proximity, you know, it's just there.
It's one of those deals where, you know,
I don't know, if you weren't a
bar four nights a fucking week,
I would think the odds of you would,
would go up exponentially. Yes.
I just said that. So, yeah,
it is, it is hard to not, uh,
to not drink. I already answered
this shit, you know, I dunno,
but I gotta tell you it's fucking
boring as hell to be out here. It,
this does not,
drinking is actually put me on edge.
MMM. I mean, you should.
The way I've lived this
week out here in the road.
If I live my entire life like this,
I could run for president and
I wouldn't have to hire the,
I wouldn't need any hush money.
Okay.
I've worked out the first day I went
to the grocery store, I bought food.
I've got a little fridge here.
I've been eating healthy.
I went to the gym every single day.
I even brought my little practice drum
pad thing with me fucking around learning
some rudiments.
I wrote jokes,
e okay. I looked at some internet
porn. All right. Right there. That,
that would fucking lose governatorial
fucking race gubernatorial or whatever the
fuck they say it. But you
know, that's the last thing.
If I could just cut out
the fucking internet porn,
mmm.
I would be completely
bored. That's, you know,
I gotta tell you that's
what I am right now.
I am sober right now and
I am not feeling this,
this unbelievable fucking high of like,
wow,
I can't believe all this shit.
Um, I, I was missing. All
I'm thinking right now is,
I can't believe how fucking
long the day is. You know,
thank God I stayed up until
four in the morning last night,
so I didn't wake up until 11,
you know,
but then you end up feeling like a loser
because now it's already fucking one.
I Dunno. I think I'm done.
Everybody. If I don't drink,
I don't think I can do the road anymore
and I don't think I'm going to be
fucking selling DVDs after
my show. I decided I'm not
fucking doing this anymore.
I'm going to be stones fucking sober
and just seeing a mirror image of what a
fucking Moron I've been all these
years. All right. Overrated. Underrated.
Um, I didn't, I don't know that
I actually got any this week,
so I actually throw in a couple of mine.
I probably got some and I just, Oh,
it's tough.
During the weeks I traveled to try to
save all these fucking emails between my
blackberry and this, this, uh,
computer here. So a overrated,
I say expensive jeans. I
remember when, you know,
if you had a pair of Levi's, you were
cool. You were in the club, right?
And what were they? 30, 40 bucks. And
then people, all of a sudden diesel jeans,
that was the first expensive
jeans I remember in this,
this girl was talking me into buying
them and they were like 180 bucks,
hundred and 60 bucks. This is, you
know, this is like eight years, seven,
eight years ago. I remember like, how do
I need $80 for a pair of fucking Jesus?
Ridiculous. I can buy four or five
pairs of Levi's. And she says like, no,
but you'll see the quality's better.
They last longer and you
know what they don't,
I think they look a little better.
I think nice jeans look better.
Like at this point then like,
you know there's,
I mean I think we can all agree there's
nothing worse than gap jeans, you know,
and they have like that sort of, not quite
stonewashed look to them, but you know,
they just look,
you just look broke.
I notice a lot of white
dudes and like their,
their 30s and forties will be wearing
those and they'll have like a button down
sort of like,
I'm going to go see Jimmy Buffet shirt
on and they'll tuck it into that and then
they'll have a pair of dirty white all
white Seinfeld sneakers on and it is just
like,
wow dude,
you are fucking married
with children because uh,
that is if ever,
if there was the anti pussy,
that is the anti everything that is
just the asexual outfit that you could
possibly be wearing. So I've been one of
these guys who get sucked into buying,
you know, more of these expensive jeans
and these fucking things they wear out.
They wear out. Just like,
you know, you don't want to,
you want to make your jeans last,
you've got to buy like fucking five
pairs and you've got to revolve them.
That's how you make them less. But
if you're wearing them, you know,
every two to three days, like I
do like a fucking, I'll tell you,
he knows the most filthiest
motherfuckers out there are musicians.
I can't believe I forgot to
tell this story. Right? Uh,
last week when I was flying back
from Providence, Rhode Island,
I decided to upgrade to first class.
I just said, fuck it. You know,
I'll deal with the fucking credit card
bill who was one of those deals where I
just didn't want to fly and I'm so sick
of fucking flying. And they were like,
Hey, do you want to upgrade to
first class? And I was like,
of course I do. And they go, well, we're
just going to put our virgin island,
fucking airline Dick in your ass.
And I was like, you know what?
I don't give a Shit Gad and raped me.
I want to fucking sit in a lazy boy,
the entire fucking ride across
the country. So that's what I do.
So I'm sitting down and on the plane
comes to skinny dude with his big titted
girlfriend and they're like,
is there anyway you could switch seats
with that so we could sit together and I
was like apps or fucking locally,
if I was in coach right now,
I'll give you a dirty look and get
may give you some sort of bullshit.
I'm superstitious, I'm not changing my
seat. Fuck you and your love affair.
But I was in first class and now
I'm affable. Absolutely. Absolutely.
So I walked over and I sat in my seat
and they will fucking sit in there.
The first thing is dirty ass musician
does. He's got these flip flops on, right?
And His fucking toes,
it looks like you know.
Now I know why people wash Jesus's feet.
That's all I can fucking tell you. Okay?
This fucking guy, he looked like
he looked like a bird of prey.
That's the only way to describe his
fucking toenails and everything.
And he did the most disgusting fucking
thing I've ever seen a human being do.
Halfway through the flight.
This mother fucker gets up to
use the bathroom on the airplane.
And I'm going to say that airport airplane
bathrooms are some of the dirtiest
fucking bathrooms ever,
just from turbulence alone.
And the fact that it's so fucking cramp,
this dirty motherfucker,
he got up in his bare feet and just
walked into the bathroom and his fucking
bear faith. I couldn't believe it. I,
I was just as does this, no fuck, there's
no fucking way. There is no fucking,
and he just walked right in there.
I mean,
he should've got a tetanus shot when he
came out. I couldn't fucking believe it.
How filthy is that? And you know what
kills me? Women love fucking love.
Musicians absolutely love him.
CanNot get on their knees quick enough
to jump down into their crab infested
pubes and stick that fucking
read in their mouth. You know,
could give a fuck,
could give a fuck about comedians.
What are women doing after
the end of the comedy show?
They come up and they'd say,
you're a loser for the place
you're fucking working in.
And then talk about what a piece
of shit you are really loudly,
which brings me to my underrated,
underrated for the week.
Learning how to play an instrument.
Unbelievably underrated. You know,
cause if you really stick with it,
you can get in a band.
And I see even if you suck,
you're going to get some pussy
and a, and if not, it's just,
it's so much better than reading and
it's better than, you know, you read,
what are you doing? You
know, you're getting smarter.
So what are you making the person's
day next to you better you're not,
but you actually learn how to play guitar.
You can play drums or something like
that. I Dunno. I just think it's,
I think it's a great
fucking thing. Um, you know,
I'm actually excited because I actually,
you know,
I told you guys I bought this Les Paul
Guitar and by the way, God rest his soul.
You know, Les Paul died this
weekend. I'm really bummed.
I never got a chance to see that guy.
That guy was still playing shows
every Monday night in New York City.
And when I was back in New
York for the month of June,
I actually tried to go see the guy.
And um,
unfortunately the night I was open
where I could go see him, he was a,
he wasn't performing that night, so I
didn't get a chance to see him. And uh,
I'm really sad about it
because, um, I dunno,
that guy is legendary
and I'm trying to see who I would
put that guy up with. I mean, he,
he's right up there with, for
me anyways, all the inventors,
I'm so stupid, Jesus Christ. But you're
gonna put them up there with Einstein,
the light bulb because the guy
fucking did something with a guitar.
You know what I'm going to hit my world
is important. If you guys, if you're not,
if you're not into a, if you don't play
an instrument or anything like that, just,
just Google images for a Gibson Les
Paul and just look at how beautiful that
Qataris. It's literally, it's
literally a fucking work of art.
And even if I didn't attempt to play
guitar, I think I would still own one.
Rather than going out
and buying a painting,
I would actually buy a Les Paul because
that's how fucking beautiful they are.
But anyways,
I'm actually learning how to play guitar.
And a last week I discovered drop d
tuning and it might've been the greatest
sound I think I've ever produced
as a human being on that Les Paul.
It's just fucking sounded unbelievable.
And uh,
I can't wait to get back to my
apartment to take out that guitar,
to not read, to not watch TV and be
informed on what's going on in the world.
So I can continue to sound like a moron
on this podcast so some people can
continue to take me seriously and
tell me how fucking dumb I am,
even though that is my point of view.
What am I talking about? All right,
let's wrap up with this.
Now. You know, we have to do,
we actually have to hype some of my
shit. Okay. And by we, I mean me,
I need to get better at this type of
stuff. All right. And this is what I'm,
I am going to be hyping for the rest
of the biggest date that I have on the
horizon for me,
believe it or not,
is my Improv Gig in
Ontario, California. Okay.
I live in Los Angeles and I'm not able
to perform out in the La area because I
have not shown to the
clubs that I am a draw.
You know, it's a, it's a weird,
I gotta I gotta get on the, the,
the Latino radio stations out
there so I can get, you know,
a significant portion of the population
to at least kind of know who the hell I
am. Because, you know, I don't want to
get on a fucking plane every other week.
I just don't want to do it.
Um,
I just don't want to hear every once
in a while I would like to fucking,
you know,
just be able to get in a car and drive.
Like I did when I lived on the east coast.
I drive down to Philly,
I drive up to Boston,
I take the fucking train down to DC,
you know. So anyways, I have this Gig
at the Improv in Ontario, California.
It's a from September 17th through
the 20th for the love of God.
Can you and 58 of your closest friends
buy some tickets and come out to that
show? I never beg people to come
out to my chefs. Maybe I do, but I,
I don't gravel right now.
I'm groveling for the love of God.
Please show up to that show so I can
somehow just have one weekend during the
year when I don't have to fucking,
you know,
just be sitting there in row
33 Gandy attention please.
This is a very full flight. All of the
overhead spaces going to be used up.
So if you have one of your smaller,
smaller containers,
if you could just put it underneath your
seat and please don't put your jackets
in the overhead compartments. This is
a very full flight and you know what?
Everybody fucking blows it off and they're
sticking lunchboxes and for length,
fucking full length fucking
coats as the ladies say in that.
So just once I flying Tang
is four hours in 58 minutes.
Um, I would just, you know,
every once in awhile we'd like to not
have to fucking listen to that so I could
just perform. And a in California,
so for the love of God,
could you southern California people,
I know you got a lot of options for the
love of God. Can you come out to my show?
Thank you.
All right,
other dates I have in September
I'm going to be in Philadelphia,
the city of brotherly love.
Do you guys beat the Braves last night?
I know that shit was going on. And what
do we got here? A helium comedy club.
I'm going to be there from September 10th
through the 12th and I got a big date
coming up in a, the Improv, Addison,
Texas September 24th through the 26th
possibly the 27th because I think I'm
hanging around on Monday night because
the cowboys got a football game and my
life is awesome and I'm going to go to
the fucking game and I'm going to look at
those fucking blonde,
big titted fucking Dallas whores
with their Mary Kay cosmetics.
You know who likes those broads? Is
that guy from the playboy, the playboy.
Ya what the fuck's his name?
That Hugh Hefner, you know,
he's really into that Tex Mex. Not text
messed up. Fucking Texarkana, Oklahoma,
that big round pie face fucking
bleach blonde looking girl.
You know,
you know those girls I'm talking about.
Hey you, how are you doing? How
y'all doing those fucking girls.
Do you guys watch that show, that show
when he had those three girlfriends,
I only thought one of them was hot. The
other two were kind of a mess. You know,
the athletic ones,
she was fucking smoking.
That girl was hot and those other two
girls, I had absolutely no use for them.
You know,
just cause you dye your hair blonde and
you're in shape doesn't mean you're good
looking. Um, all right.
I know I got a lot of fucking nerve
balding redhead fucking throwing down like
that. All right, let's, let's
fucking get on with it. All right.
That's the a podcast for this week that
I did on a Sunday and I'll be uploading
this thing, um, as I always
do right around midnight.
Just to make sure that I,
I never post them on a Sunday.
If I posted it on a Sunday,
then it would be a very
special Monday morning podcast.
And this one isn't special.
This was sort of me bitching,
which is sort of the standard. So anyways,
I hope you guys all have a great week.
Once again, thanks to everybody
over at Capitol records.
Let me take a tour of that
building. I had an I, you know,
one of the greatest things I've ever
gotten to do all seriousness and uh,
please come out to my shows. Uh, the next
show I have coming up is in a Stockholm,
Sweden. So if anybody
overseas is listening to this,
if you live in Copenhagen,
Denmark,
evidently you can get in your car
and drive to fucking sweep now. Huh?
Or least I just discovered you.
Could you go over that bridge and then
to the island and then into the fucking
tunnel. So why don't you come on
over and watch me talk. My Shit.
That is all the data's October,
August 29th when I'm doing
it. All right, I'm done.
Well, you guys have a good
week. All right. Take it easy.
We have taken to the streets.
We are dancing. No
black. Walt's bad parents
rose to this ladder.
There's a picture black and white for your
snitcher
sticks and stones app made me smarter.
Squirts that car under my arm. Did I say
no?
Cause no body is,
we are waiting on a town
camp.
I'm sorry to report.
We have taken to the streets. Great. John.
We are dancing on black walls.
Oh.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].